which joining me now is the mayor of
London Sadiq Khan a very good afternoon
to you Sadiq Khan thanks so much for
talking to us
um the Met Police Commissioner has
released some staggering figures that
have been Unearthed today including one
of them in four out of five cases he
says involving officers who've faced
allegations of sexual or domestic
violence he says that concerns still
remain how worried are you about some of
the statistics coming out from his
review
like other londoners and people across
the country of course I'm appalled and
disturbed by the findings of the new
commissioner but also I recognize these
are important and necessary steps if
we're going to change our Police Service
from being one that's institutionally
racist institutely misogynistic
institutionally homophobic to unless
anti-racist anti-misogynistic and
hierophobic and it shows actually that
this new commissioner is making progress
first steps to reform in our Police
Service but we've got to recognize we're
still in the foothills of reform
well yes and what should that formula
look like 161 officers have been found
to have criminal convictions another
statistic he's produced today should an
officer in your view be sacked if they
have a criminal conviction whatever that
might be
well first I think if you're a police
officer the standards expected of you
should be higher than in other jobs in
society I think there may be exceptional
circumstances where somebody has a
conviction when they were very young uh
for for a non-serious offense that has
been spent and they should be allowed to
be rehabilitated and join the Police
Service that is a real exception what
can't be right is there are police
officers with convictions to do with
sexual offenses to do with drink driving
to do with violence who are police
officers and the problem is this it's
far too easy to be a police officer and
it's far too hard to get kicked out of
the police service that's why for some
time now I've been lobbying the
government to change the national
veteran rules to make it more difficult
to be a join a police service but also
to change the misconduct rules to make
it easier to get rid of bad police
officers that's the only way we're going
to change the culture in the police
service and the culture needs to be
changed in the Police Service
well yes and smart really has also said
that it is nonsensical that he doesn't
have the power to dismiss officers and
as you say it is hard to sack them isn't
it and I think the Home Secretary has uh
is is up to her to review the
regulations at present so what you're
saying is you would back any move to
make it easier to sack police officers
absolutely she's the latest in a lot of
Home secretaries I've been lobbying to
change the law for some time now we've
been calling for these uh reforms we've
bolstered the Professional Standards
team so more officers can be
investigated we've opened up a hotline
so as the public can ring the Police
Service police officers who have got
concerns about other officers can ring a
met uh hotline the police under sir
Mark's leadership have sped up the time
it takes to investigate complaints but
also as you've said he's looking back 10
years against any officer or police
staff against human allegations made of
domestic abuse and sexual offenses but
it feels like we're dealing with one
hand tied behind our back in relation to
the lack of support from the government
no support financially from the
government to make these uh reforms and
no support in relation to changing the
law it's really important that the
government supports Us in relation to
Transforming Our Police Service
londoners deserved this and need this
nearly 100 met police officers are being
moved to try to tackle this issue of
rooting out unfit officers and improving
standards it means they're moving though
from from crime squads and priorities
like tackling crime and terrorism are
you worried about the Gap that leaves
I am concerned of course we in London
are 1400 officers short of a number of
officers we should have so if the
government gives us those offices we
need it makes this job a bit easier but
it's about priorities is one of our
priorities to improve trusted confidence
in the police amongst ordinary lunders
it is one of our priorities to make sure
we change the culture in our Police
Service is one of our priorities to get
rid of those bad police officers who are
serving police officers that means
moving 90 officers from doing really
important crime fighting in this part of
the Police Service to the Professional
Standards to moment and the reason why
that's important is because Dame Louise
Casey found in her interim report that
it was taken far too long to investigate
officers against him allegations had
been made the average length of a case
before so Mark became commissioner was
more than 430 days that can't be right
that led to other officers losing
confidence and reports in offices
because it's taking so long to
investigate their particular complaint
also known as the public made a
complaint it took years for their
complaint to be investigated so I
support someone in relation to moving
offices to the Professional Standards
team but also another reason for the
government to support us by giving us
the resources we need for these 1400
extra officers that London needs
you sound frustrated that the state that
the Met police is in and yet as mayor of
London you're effectively elected police
commissioner of the Met do you have any
regrets over your oversight of some of
these issues of criminality within the
the Force and and the problems amongst
unfit officers
it gives me no pleasure at all no
pleasure at all in being Vindicated for
some years now I've been raising these
issues shining a light on these issues
as a young Londoner when I walked this
city I was often stopped and searched by
the police for no reason as a young
mother to drive in my car I was often
stopped by the police for no good reason
as a lawyer I gave evidence to the home
Affairs select committee trying to bring
about reform and also I gave evidence to
the McPherson report for the last few
years as the mayor I've been trying to
bring about change that's ultimately
what led to me asking for the
independent review into the police
systems and cultures from Dame Louise
Casey's ultimately what led me to lose
confidence in the former commissioner
and What's led me to appoint this new
commission I see reform in the Police
Service as a critical part of my
morality London is a survey Police
Service that looks like them but also
has high standards
okay Sadiq Khan mayor of London we
appreciate your time this afternoon
thanks very much indeed for sharing your
views with this today
thank you